welcome oops no I had that one playing
agent Fox Mulder welcome to that video
yeah I've got a small winning streak
going on let's keep that let's play the
opening quickly not spend too much time
so I think bishop age seven but that's a
simple tag tag that doesn't doesn't
strike I'm not quite sure I always
forget the move orders in this opening
if you go look see one or before or
whatever I looked at this really ages
ago ages and I simply cannot recall the
precise move orders yeah sometimes this
is good sometimes not Queen f6 is a
movie and I really can never make sense
of the correct timing sometimes it's
good for wine sometimes it's not so kind
of curious what happens here yeah he
went to have six and he can't eat at
three now get to that end game I mean
I've got two bishops that's cool but
it's a pretty job pretty unique kind of
kind of structure so what is this point
he probably wants to go Bishop to c7
here I can prevent that bit before maybe
let's do that Bishop c7 I can take b5 at
you lose the piece
before however this weekend the C 3
square maybe am I should have thought
about that a bit longer that long-term
consequence could be far more important
than that little trick in fact that's
quite likely ok anyway let's continue
not second-guessing too much yeah if I
if you go be five let's get more space
the night doesn't have a really great
square 97 Bishop b6 is certainly nothing
to be afraid of what did he expect that
I don't play be five I don't know okay
it's going back that's an interesting
choice
okay let's gain some space 97 95 or Roxy
three rocks III is definitely a move mmm
therefore I should have thought about
that a little bit longer it was the
dress to a bit too bit too quickly
played I it's a bit difficult not to
take that
rook c8 should look see it okay if I go
I mean Bishop c5 s may be coming which I
can answer with Lucas III as long as
it's not a check so let's move the King
makes Bishop c5 impossible 95 I can also
take on c3 so maybe this one threatening
Bishop g5 yeah let's see now not sefa
let's see five years night Biz Markie I
can go to see tune a very difficult
position and then rook the one Bishop
see to look you wan very complicated and
game I have one thing in my favor my
king is this really active I'm using
I've got it near the porn it's important
getting possible bishops III in some
positions yeah here 3rd Rock Tijuana
isn't that good we should be 5f for that
it's definitely not bad
why can't just take actually I can take
a rooty five winning a pawn maybe that's
not so clear but something for him to
worry but it was quick for once and what
else actually what what else to CF move
other than Bishop b5 ultimately he
couldn't find one if I go F for now he
will go all the way back I it's not a
bad position but I can take and rock d5
that's a very direct way to do it let's
say b6 rookie five rook d 8 and he's got
rocked it to coming mmm that feels a bit
annoying I cannot really i mean i can go
look the fire but it looks wrong take
stakes king of something as a deform i
might win the c3 porn that way
mm I don't I soon like that doesn't that
doesn't seem seem right to me if he goes
back I wonder if be 6 i'm actually like
we should be 8 b 6
my general ideas if he goes back i go
king of three Bishop g1 and activate
this Bishop again and well his pawn is
very safely blocked night she wants to
put the night down so that's important
night might come to be three and then d
4 or something I can go rook d4 Knight
b3 route 84
it's looked it too dangerous and don't
think so come on okay so time when we
found some some syntactic a chick is 793
it's not okay to a shame don't they have
something better here I can check it i
can check your first chef then take a
seven it really only has a checker at
best and crafts with jhalak resins okay
I was a very difficult position so I was
very interesting this this kind of
endgame is interesting yeah i mean this
this was a very yeah quick decision to
prevent bishop c7 but if we can see
three which had far-reaching
consequences as we saw this this here
okay that's not liked by the engine it
wants to go bishop he and Bishop b5
interesting yeah why not that's a good
idea ok so it doesn't like this because
of 97 and this is not regarded as so
good five i don't know i mean i like it
i like my position here to be honest I
think and now the engine also agree is
giving me a pretty substantial advantage
it is difficult to same it wants to the
comp wants to go g6 in this position
giving me allowing this and then play
like this
and successes that is equal this is an
important idea I interesting it has
gained the c6 square the trade of f5 has
gained the square that's interesting
okay let's say that's an important
improvement around he I mean in great
shape I didn't think that this is so
great and if i take it I thought rook e8
routine 5 yes I saw that line but I
wasn't sure if I'm I'm really winning
here okay the computer gives f6 okay I
didn't see this point but ok this is
also just good for white I mean no no
question here it is good Oh night be
three I overlooked something there what
did I overlooked that wins after looks
you forward what is the big idea night
a1a no no sorry I overlooked that move I
didn't see it I didn't see that that
would have been a cold shower we'll just
lose this bishop Wow okay yeah will you
know nothing Wow so I really allowed a
big I mean not a big tactic but the big
turnaround Jen if you would have played
that B 3 night a one as the caneva it's
not very human move but it happens okay
well at least I'm over 2,300 again
thanks for watching